the thing about Elon Musk is if you
listen to that 90 minutes
he is like a kid who found a new toy
it's like Christmas day and you open the
box and I've got a new toy what's the
toy the Toy's politics I guarantee this
guy hasn't had a political thought for
the last 40 years and then up comes
censorship up comes open border up comes
everything else and he goes huh
what what what's this Hunter Hunter
Biden laptop thing
why can't I retweet the New York Post
story about it before the election
he's found politics and he's playing
with it he doesn't know what he is he
doesn't know whether he's a Libertarian
or a conservative he just knows people
are attacking America that has given him
Fortune beyond belief and are attacking
the First Amendment and he doesn't like
it he could be he could be the George
Soros for the good guys but he's also
got some ties to China that are
problematic business ties whatever but
you know my metric when people say to me
you know he's he's just another one of
the elitists
pissed off all the right people in the
last year the enemies he has made are
all the right enemies from The
Washington Post to CNN to the Democrats
the AOC if you're pissing off those
people who hate America you're probably
a good guy
yeah you know there's a um it's funny
you're saying that 40 years he's not you
know he just kind of got a hold of this
but knowing his style of a student and
curious he is I can only imagine how
obsessed and immersed he is with wanting
to know everything learn everything
about the space if that's the case if
you're saying that's the case uh and if
he becomes a True Believer uh that's a
pretty heavy weight of a true do you
have any thoughts on the guy on the
person he just hired us yeah do you have
any thoughts on it I'm curious so I I
saw all this stuff about her being you
know she's a leftist well economic Forum
executive director look at the interview
she did with him it's all work I watched
the interview it was it wasn't wasn't
bad and you know it's fascinating the
finance my engineer my radio show he
sent me a clip of the financial times
where it's two unnamed sources uh senior
Executives in advertising said yeah if I
had to class her I'd say Linda's
probably a Reagan Republican
and then I go to fight is this woman on
Twitter
and I go on Twitter
she's following me Patrick
now if you're watching your movies you
know you have to be I mean having me on
your show you got balls so God bless you
for having me in your show right because
as far as you know the left is concerned
I I am you know the the devil incarnate
you know Trump's what did the telegraph
call me Trump's pit bull right when I
was in the white house if she's I don't
have a lot of big uh ad Executives
following me on Twitter I mean I've got
a million plus followers but big big ad
Executives I think she's probably the
only one now that's interesting and my
producer who has the best political
his the marrow bone he can he can sniff
out a a fake person instantly he said
yeah you know why he hired her
because the biggest problem with Twitter
now and you've seen it on your feed are
the crap ads I mean he's been hammered
since he took her over they have been
targeting him the left has to get rid of
his advertisers he needs to make that
platform profitable he wants to turn it
into the Amazon Plus Facebook plus
YouTube of the future super app yeah he
says I want this that the app you only
need one app to shop and watch your
videos and do so this is the app now you
can't do that without money without it
being profitable he's just hired a
professional and he can fire her
whenever he wants this is a woman who's
there to bring in ad revenue and I I'm
not worried about this woman not at all
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]